Rusia exige que se desmilitarice el
corredor de granos en el mar Negro para
volver a permitir el paso de cargueros
la Casa Blanca asegura que es una
extorsión y hace unos minutos el
presidente Putin dijo que no es tan
finalizando su participación en el
acuerdo de exportación de granos sino
suspendiéndola cómo se ve la situación
de los barcos cargados que Ya partieron
y los que planean zarpar en los próximos
días
bien hay un impase que va a implicar la
comprometer seriamente la posibilidad de
que la provisión de alimentos el cuerno
de África y a otras regiones aledañas a
Turquía se pueda concretar recordemos
que este fue un acuerdo en un momento
distinto de la guerra la descomposición
de el diálogo y de las posibilidades
diplomáticas está llevando a afectar
ahora dos frentes que durante un
invierno como el europeo van a ser
críticos en términos de ya situación
humanitaria el frente de la energía los
europeos no pueden estar sin energía
eléctrica no pueden estar sin provisión
de energía durante el invierno y los
alimentos ya estamos sufriendo el
bloqueo de estas 16 naves que entiendo
yo van a estar ahí en el en el mar Negro
imposibilitadas de transitar hacia
somalia hacia Etiopía hacia lugares
donde es crítico en este momento la
provisión de alimento y de grano
históricamente viniendo de Ucrania y de
la unión y de Rusia no entonces creo que
la guerra está degenerando en en el cual
ya es inevitable que terceros sean
partícipes el tema de los alimentos está
poniendo a Turquía en el escenario y el
tema de los drones que se han usado para
atacar infraestructura eléctrica han
metido a Irán de alguna manera en el
conflicto bueno empecé a las amenazas
del kremlin el presidente aseguró que
continuarán exportándose cereales y
Naciones Unidas también dijo que siguen
comprometidos con el pacto ya usted lo
estaba mencionando Pero le pido que
profundicemos en el impacto para los
mercados y para las personas si se frena
esta exportación de granos
bien en el área a nivel mundial la
provisión de granos tienen un impacto
del 25% mundial solamente lo que produce
en términos de trigo Ucrania y también
Rusia es decir en un impase en este
punto del planeta neurasia para la
provisión de granos no afecta ni
siquiera solamente Europa es decir la
dimensión del daño la dimensión de la
provisionamiento va a ser por ahora los
países que le mencionaba Etiopía eritrea
somalia en el cuerno pero se va a
extender no sobre Europa sino también va
a empezar a afectar el precio de los
granos aquí en Latinoamérica y en los
Estados Unidos Bueno le pregunta
brevemente los ataques rusos contra
Ucrania ya no solo están afectando la
red eléctrica sino también este
suministro de agua de alguna manera
Rusia está decidiendo castigar
deliberadamente a los civiles como
medida de presión
pienso que ese es el punto al que ha
avanzado el conflicto ha degenerado en
un conflicto que ya tiene tiene dados
los los los blancos civiles y a eso está
de cajón la infraestructura eléctrica
los servicios básicos es parte de lo que
ya se convierte en una guerra no no
simétrica no en la guerra asimétrica que
está buscando blancos no bélicos
tradicionalmente y va a generar por
supuesto un enorme da